well boys we did it i'm banned from
china
that's right after i spoke about the
hong kong protest
and showed their leader being mocked as
looking like winnie the pooh i got
banned from china that's right now if
you search anything pewdiepie related
on any reddit related forum in china
or youtube related videos it will just
be completely blank
i'm laughing but yeah i'm sorry if you
are in china and try to watch my videos
that's that kind of sucks it's just kind
of funny
like i knew it was gonna happen the
music artist zed got bad in china just
because he
liked the south park tweet so obviously
me talking about the hong kong memes
was gonna get me banned but you know
who's not banned in china
bart baker that's right
i stumble upon this thanks to joel and
it's the most confusing thing
i have ever seen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i like that he changes his own english
to just fit the chinese market so
bart baker for those who don't know bart
baker this is beautiful
this is the best thing i've seen ever i
saw this and i'm like this has to be a
joke
but it's so obviously not a joke bart
baker
uh has 10 million subscribers on youtube
he's done a parody of
practically everything i'm not going to
play his songs because it'll get
copyrighted but
you know he's collaborated with stevo
joey graceffa
his parodies are not bad it's not my
type of humor but
some of them are actually good i'll give
him that bartbaker's channel has
3 billion views but now
[Music]
she can sing we check this style out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i am obsessed as one could ever
now bart records himself with face
filters
translating chinese songs into english
she can sing
but check this out that seems to be a
winning formula for bart
okay that guy's voice is awesome but
check this out
notice how he keeps changing the side of
the microphone that's the correct way of
the microphone i have the same one but
i guess he realized it looks cooler if
you hold the microphone the wrong way
[Laughter]
i don't know why i'm pointing that out
but that's like the least embarrassing
thing out of all of this
you can always go on tour mr baker
please get out of live streaming
at the next contract if you sign five
year term or higher
you wouldn't be able to leave unless you
pay millions to the company
oh how far have you fallen oh god it's
so bizarre
[Music]
[Applause]
hit that follow button and make sure to
like this let's see if we notice how his
eyes just got bigger
because the face filter discovered it
[Music]
okay hold on that's cool but check this
dollar
[Music]
it sounded better before bart i'm sorry
well we know why now because vice did a
documentary
about him and it's pretty sad and i'm
not gonna lie it's
pretty sad
come on come on
ready let's go let's go bart works from
home
and he's got a routine wake up early
walk the dog grab coffee wow he's so
cool
and get to do what he's always done best
this feels like you're watching a
delusional superstar
right and why why is this the face you
make when you put in
anything in your eye like why is it
impossible to touch your eye without
opening your mouth
i know that's a side track but it i will
it always bothers me
by 8 am he's already clocked in oh yeah
vandal dropped wall
do you love china why don't work why do
you think i got huawei
why huawei nihao
[Laughter]
that's how you know you truly love china
if you have a huawei
nothing to do with sponsorships
i see you tomorrow or maybe i'll see you
tonight i don't know i'll see you in the
morning
what what was that sentence
jesus jesus
this is satire because if it is it's so
brilliant
it's genius bart was a classic youtube
success story
his specialty was parody music videos
imitating pop stars like taylor swift
and justin bieber he'd get tens of
millions of hits on his most popular
videos
right some of bart's most popular songs
have 200 million views like if he got a
sponsor in that
that would be a lot of money i assume he
doesn't get those numbers anymore and
that's why he turned to this
but a couple years ago youtube started
dropping channels that weren't family
friendly from their preferred program
in order to attract advertisers is this
my fault bart
i'm sorry suddenly big name youtubers
like bart
saw the revenue drop to a fraction of
what it used to be
i don't think that's necessarily the
issue the issue is that now
short videos are not as monetizable as
longer ones
youtube youtube changed in 2016 was it
that they want more watch time instead
of views so content that
that gets a lot of numbers and isn't as
valuable
as longer videos that's just how it is
music videos aren't long
they don't make many much money it's
like lasagna
has like 200 million views but it's
probably
made less money than this video and it
used to be fine on youtube
actually like the more edgy it was the
better
fast forward a year and a half maybe and
you know i'm like super miserable uh
going to a therapist
because youtube yeah yeah you don't know
how many youtubers are depressed
if bart is happier doing uh chinese
content i'm happy for him don't get me
wrong
like i get it youtube is very stressful
if you're not on top of what you're
doing you're done and that's just the
reality of the
of being a youtuber and that puts a lot
of pressure on you so
so anyway all this [ __ ] was going on and
i was super unhappy and i get an email
and it's like um
we're a company from china we think you
could be very big in china
i gotta listen to the song they sent me
and then i have to translate it and then
i have to record it then i have to shoot
the video
then i have to edit it it's like it's
back to the basics
but in china how do you change it i put
the chinese into google translate
and then i have to make all the words
rhyme so that's what the fans are into
that's what got the uh accounts really
popular
[Music]
the world is passing by the
tide is rushing how much of this are you
able to do when it
you don't actually know what's being
said in chinese
oh it's all i don't know any of it red
death star rolling
red dust red dust red dust i get that a
lot a lot of red dust
and these lyrics i know i'm that red
dust you get scattered by
this company in china what was it that
they liked about you
they said that the first thing they do
is look at how you look
what do you think they're looking for
well with a western
person i mean blonde hair helps this
isn't even my real hair color
so basically they like nothing about you
like
anyone can get a blonde hair dye this
died i dyed my hair the day before that
video got 30 million views
and then that video hits so hard how
much of the success
what is he talking about can be
attributed to the fact that you're white
a small amount to start a good amount to
start actually
a tiny porsche actually it's pretty yeah
it's good it's good actually
it's good being white in china okay so
bart explained that
they came to him because they saw
potential here's what they actually said
about bart which is the saddest thing
what makes you decide
this guy i can make him a hit here um
we didn't think he was anything special
he's so mean
he's not very happy
about this
bitay and bart would make their money
but in order to be brand friendly
bart's gotta be child friendly china
you're awesome
this one's for you and some of bart's
biggest hits so far are patriotic songs
about china oh
[Music]
might say something politically that
would get
you and him in trouble that he just
doesn't know that's wrong yet
yeah definitely don't say anything about
hong kong grace resentment
life and death by a few
can be seen
[Music]
that was okay you're trying to hit the
inga
how is this real and all that hard work
might just pay off for bart
he's all in he's even moving to china
this week
[Music]
that's a wrap a lot easier than youtube
video
is it really he just looks like a
middle-aged white guy who is
so lost in life it's sad how the person
who made everyone laugh is depressed now
bart looks like he's dying in the inside
but he yeah i mean
what did he say when he stopped the
video okay
hope you'll get warm i'll see you
tomorrow or maybe i'll see you tonight i
don't know i'll see you in the morning
bye
jesus jesus
ah this dude looks 40 and 18 at the same
time
this is the thing everyone in life is
driven to do what they
think makes them happy but that will
take some people on some very
strange paths i want to watch some more
of his videos
[Music]
okay that sounds amazing but check out
the english
is a version that i can't shake you from
my mind
but you brush me off it makes me wanna
cry
stop with the silence please girl tell
me why
but maybe you've already
[Music]
i think this just shows just how
competitive it is online
and that you you need a niche and bart
has
found one i guess bart baker promotes
anti-americanism
in china you guys asked for it so we're
doing it today we're going to the huawei
store to get a p30 pro
and destroy the iphone
[Music]
well now i don't need an apple iphone
you guys think i can get away
wearing that or do you think that might
be a problem that t-shirt
by the way come here this is a real
iphone this isn't fake this is my phone
this is my new phone baby
[Music]
this thing is broken well i want one
oh my god you did this youtube you did
this
bart baker and bio bi is he like a big
deal or something
bart is literally that that one guy that
appears in other people's songs and
you're like
wait who is that where did they come
from he's that of china
bart became what he's making fun of an
idol
god if this was parody it would be i
would respect it so much
well i wonder who's next on the train
maybe jake paul
you know if it becomes more beneficial
to make these videos than youtube i mean
people
are gonna do it maybe bart is just a
trendsetter you know
maybe he's just the the first who
saw the potential that would be funny
too i can never join him in a step
because i'm bad in china
this is so sad
[Music]
[Music]
oh god
[Laughter]
oh my god all right honestly behind this
seems bart seems like a
decent dude i don't have any quarrel
with him everyone's gonna get bread on
that
table and i guess he's found his niche
so props to him
i kind of hope this turns out to be a
joke because that would make it
really brilliant i don't i'm pretty sure
it isn't
which makes it even funnier so i hope
you guys enjoyed this video smash like
oh wait sorry guys sorry i did it wrong
what's up guys hope you enjoyed that
video if you enjoyed it smash a like on
this video
and if you leave a comment
about this pen one is gonna win this pen
signed
with this pen follow me on twitter
instagram and vine and check out more of
my videos over there
and remember to subscribe it's also
everything i hate about youtube so
welcome what you haven't tried tuber
simulator seriously
after 50 million outros
maya god damn it
still relevant just download it